more earthquake aftershocks hit haiti
overnight while the death toll there
rose to more than two thousand officials
say more than half a million survivors
need help and some say it's not moving
fast enough vlad duchess shows us how
haitians are helping each other in one
of the hardest hit areas
we're here at this hospital
the united states coast guard is also
here they've rescued numerous victims
and have brought in thousands of pounds
of supplies to the affected areas
across haiti hospitals are overwhelmed
doctors are struggling to treat
thousands of earthquake victims as even
more trickle in from remote areas in
search of medical care five days after
the quake you can see the hospital is
full
patients are overflowing and they've
been put outside because all the rooms
are filled
some of these patients being treated
outside are babies and young children
concrete fell on his leg in the
earthquake
those who are more seriously injured and
need critical attention are flown to the
capitol port of prince
tens of thousands of people lost their
homes in the quake and now they're
having to wait even longer to get food
clean water and a place to stay because
of tropical storm grace
while they wait haitians are stepping up
to help each other
in this kitchen we saw locals like
colette denis making thousands of meals
to deliver to people some who have not
eaten a hot meal in days we know they
are hungry they are really hungry they
lost their houses they lost everything
so for sure that's the most important
thing for them right now is to eat to
stay alive
humanitarian missions will resume from
here this morning the most seriously
injured victims are flown from the
impacted areas while supplies go out to
survivors but for comparison gail the
death toll on day five of the 2010
earthquake was estimated at up to two
hundred thousand the death toll from
saturday is approximately two thousand
the numbers sound better you know glad i
affectionately call you the haitian
sensation because you know this country
very well you're you you have haitian
roots but i wonder what this is like for
you covering this country that you know
so well in the people so well you're
doing an amazing job but i wonder how it
feels and what it's like for you
you know it's often tragic that i'm
finding myself here in haiti gail but
one thing that i want people to remember
there are some people who've asked me on
social media wow vlad is haiti cursed
and i always reply back no in fact haiti
is a miracle haiti is a modern miracle
the first independent black nation in
the western hemisphere slaves brought
here in shackles threw off those chains
of slavery to defeat a superpower and
granted equality to all people across
this land and that is haiti's legacy
that is what they're most proud of and
as they say here it's just another
mountain to climb and climate they will
gail another mountain to climb and then
there's always another mountain on the
other side of the map on the other side
it will climb that too and they will
climb that too glad dotier thank you
very much please be careful can't wait
to see you